1 comment ça va bien ça se passe bien
bon aujourd'hui c'est un sujet comme les
noms je suis seul tabouret aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet comme le design on parle
d'un produit qui est très bien mais
voilà vous avez compris tout se situe
dans le a c'est ça c'est la microsoft
c'est là sur face book 3 qui succède à
la micro sol sur face book d'eau qui
elle-même succédé à la microsoft sans
facebook sur facebook vous avez compris
truc alors 7 microsoft sur facebook 3
elle est là elle est là elle est belle
elle divisée j'en ai fait les choses et
il est l'heure de vous dire ce que j'en
pense
et c'était très intéressant parce que
vous savez quand je bosse sur des vidéos
et bien sûr des thèses des fois on parle
de différentes choses de design de
l'écran on parle des usages qui va ce
qui va pas mais ces produits là est
extrêmement intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'il emmène une notion qui est très
cool c'est le positionnement du produit
au delà même de parler des
spécifications techniques de ce qu'on
peut faire et de ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire on peut vraiment parler du
positionnement et du choix qu'a fait
microsoft sur sa surface book 3 et ça
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement
passionnant alors ça ce sont mes notes
c'est tout ce que je vais vous dire est
ce que vous allez voir en orange
voyez la couleur orange ce sont les
points que je n'aime pas ce sont les
choses qui vont poser problème parce que
oui c'est un produit qu'on va autant
adoré dis pas qu'on va les tester mais
qui va être assez controversé parce
qu'il a posé quelques problèmes ce
produit on l'est non ne l'aiment pas en
tout cas on va en parler je vais tout
vous dire je vous dire ce que j'en pense
mais avant tout sur ce que je vous
demande c'est de revenir cliquer juste
en dessous sans bouton rouge vous venez
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous saurez tout sur l'actu dès
qu'on parle bien évidemment de pc on
parle de mac
on parle beaucoup de smartphones on
parle de monde connecté on parle de
tablettes
on parle de toute l'actu surtout on
parle de vous de vos usages à l'ego
produits numériques dont je vous invite
à vous abonner habiter son bouton
axonais accueille comme ça vous saurez
tout pouvoir gbagbo on ne peut pas
parler de ce produit sans décrire ce
produit sans dire ce qu'il est alors en
fait quand on prend comme ça on dit oui
et bien c'est le nouveau pc de microsoft
si vous connaissez la surface bukina sur
facebook elle a une fonctionnalité qui
est assez exceptionnel déjà elle a un
écran tactile ça c'est vachement bien et
surtout lorsque vous venez appuyer la
voyez vous pouvez
détachez votre ordinateur votre écran ça
vous fait donc un combo clavier tablette
vous venez ensuite leur poser à
l'horaire mais qu'est ce que je fais
n'importe quoi
non vous tapez pas n'importe quoi et là
ça se transforme en mode studio vous
allez pouvoir venir travailler comme ça
voyez dans cette config l'art avec votre
stylet parce que oui il existe un style
et ça c'est vachement bien et pouvoir à
bosser sur des croquis sur des calques
microsol tour de la présidente sur ce
que vous voulez donc ça c'est génial
maintenant il ya un vrai problème et il
ya un vrai problème parce qu'il ya des
choix qui ont été faits qui sont
extrêmement contraignant et qui postent
un vrai problème par rapport à la
définition de ce produit en lui même je
vous explique vous voulez acheter cette
décale parce qu'elle est sympa parce
qu'on a un design qui est chouette bien
qu'on l'ait déjà vu les quelques années
ça on en reparle dans quelques instants
vous voulez acheter parce que vous
voulez un pc sauf que là vous n'allez
pas acheter un pc vous allez acheter une
espèce de machine hybride mi pc et mi
tablette mi studio elle fait tout ça
elle le fait bien mais faut pas trop lui
en demander parce qu'elle est un peu
capricieuse pourquoi tout simplement
parce que dans toute la partie
supérieure qui servira tablette écran
vous avez votre processeur plus une
batterie dans la partie inférieure vous
avez votre carte graphique plus une
batterie ce qui veut dire que lorsque
vous venez enlever la partie supérieure
voilà et bien vous n'avez plus votre
carte graphique donc vous n'avez pas
pouvoir aller perdre autant de choses
notamment en terme de montage vidéo vous
allez tout de suite limité donc pour
gagner en mobilité
on va venir le perdre en performance et
c'est là que cette machine est assez
intéressante pourquoi dans ce qu'elle
définit un espèce d'hybride qui est
unique
unique en son genre qui étaient déjà là
avant avec la surface de bouc 2 donc on
connaît ce produit sauf que est ce que
en 2020 c'est encore pertinent d'avoir
un produit comme celui là pose la
question vous avez dix minutes au delà
de ça je suis passion je suis pas ça
parce qu'aujourd'hui les tablettes monte
en gamme
on peut trouver un très bon ordinateur
pour amir combinée avec une tablette qui
sera puissante vous et pouvoir avoir de
la mobilité avec un excellent produit
vous êtes pauvre un ordinateur
extrêmement puissant beaucoup moins cher
avec un design de 2020 c'est toute la
question du positionnement de ce produit
est du choix qu'a fait microsoft sur son
nouveau produit ça sur face book
3 parce que mon ordinateur je les aime
bien vous avez ces deux partis qui sont
très sympas sur tout ce que j'aime
beaucoup ici c'est cette partie là au
niveau du clavier on a toujours des
lignes très typé un clavier qui vont
vraiment très sympa et microsoft a
vraiment très très bien bossé là-dessus
la course de frappe est plutôt bonne le
retour de touche est ok
ni regretté par contre c'est ce trackpad
que je trouve beaucoup trop petit par
rapport à la taille disponible
parce que si vous comparez avec une des
références dans le domaine ici le
macbook pro qui a vraiment un excellent
clavier il ya un excellent trackpad vous
voyez que la surface elle est toute
petite
et quand j surface gelée pas de jeu de
mots et ça c'est dommage sur une machine
de cette qualité là et de ce prix là à
côté de ça on sort faire très facilement
les cliques son bonbon ça marche bien
mais c'est juste en termes de confort et
même sur des mini machine comme le xps
13 de 2020 ils ont vraiment réussi à
utiliser toute la surface pour proposer
une très grande expérience et je trouve
que voyez il fait vraiment tout petit à
côté de soi pour trouver ici bon ça
reste quand même un produit qui est
extrêmement fonctionnel qui marche bien
qui est pratique et moi ce que j'aime
bien c'est ce petit gars qu'on retrouve
ici j'ai pas si vous en rendrez bien
content ici c'est légèrement galbées le
fait de pouvoir mettre cette partie là
dessus aussi
ça marche bien et ça ça rajoute vraiment
à l'expérience
une fois qu'il est positionné on peut
plus venir l'enlever si vous voulez
l'enlever il faudra laisser votre doigt
appuyé ici pendant quelques secondes et
vous n'avez plus qu'à le retirer il a
donc le choix entre plusieurs confier le
fait de l'utiliser comme une tablette à
part entière le fait de l'utiliser comme
un pc ou le fait l'utiliser en mode
studio en venant le clip c est en venant
de rabaisser là vous n'avez plus qu'elle
tournait vous pouvez le surélever et
venir travailler prendre des notes
extrêmement facilement donc là j'ai bien
utilisé dans un mode un peu standard
mais si vous vous dites
allez j'en ai marre qu sur mon petit
bouton derrière je veux le prendre sur
les genoux est bien là vous n'avez plus
tard graphique c'est toute la
contradiction de ce produit ça lui a pas
vraiment de la flexibilité mais ça vient
aussi énormément limité parce qu'une
fois de plus votre configuration est
réparti entre ces deux produits là donc
pour mieux regarder des films des séries
de votre tablette griffonné quelques
notes faire quelque chose très légère
vous pouvez le faire mais moi si j'ai
envie de le prendre si j'ai envie de
dessiner si on est de faire de calculs
faire du photoshop temps et de faire du
montage savait faire des choses comme ça
eh bien je ne peux pas alors que si je
m'achète une tablette suffisamment
puissante dans le haut de gamme ou 13
fois pour trouver aujourd'hui notamment
avec pas de trop et compagnie est bien
là je peux le faire
voyez c'est toute la difficulté
aujourd'hui tu vas rencontrer microsoft
là dessus c'est que en 2015 c'était cool
en 2017 c'était cool
né en 2020 ça devient compliqué parce
qu'enfin vous avez des produits qui sont
très sérieux très performant et
extrêmement modulaire et encore plus si
vous regardez l'ipad pro avec le magic
qui borde sa vie un peu plus
complexifiés la faire et notamment par
rapport au prix de ce produit mais
seront en parle dans quelques instants
parce que si microsoft a dû faire des
choix par rapport à la conflit qui vous
ont proposé ne pouvait pas mettre tout
et n'importe quoi ils étaient quand même
extrêmement limité le processeur intel
core i7 de 10e génération mais est la
référence alors j'ai pas reprise par
coeur parce qu'elle est un peu complexe
c'est là il 7065 g7 à quatre coeurs
autant vous dire que vous pourriez
trouver des choses plus performantes
moins cher vous avez le choix entre 16
ou 32 gigas de ram
lp ddr4 x ça fonctionne très bien et
vous avez une carte graphique
lorsque vous l'avez en version complète
pascal gand clavier c'est une nvidia
geforce gtx 1660 tei avec max design et
avec 6 giga de mémoire gddr5
donc voyez quand vous avez tout a semblé
ça fonctionne mais c'est pas non plus la
machine est la plus performante
le stockage c'est pas mal vous avez un
ssd soit 256 giga c'est trop petit et
trop bas ne prenez pas minimum 512 ou
alors carrément intérêt on pourra
regretter ici qu'on n'est pas du
stockage en de terrain a prévu de
prononcer ce dès que vous venez
connectés là dessus bon ça ira très bien
enfin ça ira très bien oui et non parce
que une fois de plus microsoft a fait un
choix qui vise à en 2020 vous avez un
port en usb c mais ce n'est pas un port
thunderbolt roi donc si vous voulez
venir travailler en même temps sur votre
disque dur externe
vous allez voir plein d'éléments le
stocker eh bien vous ne pouvez pas ou en
tout cas ça n'ira pas suffisamment vite
alors un ssd l'extérieur pourquoi pas
mais sans thunderball trois voiliers
c'est dommage et en plus ce qui est
complètement dingue cette machine elle a
vraiment de l'adn au niveau des
créateurs et vous le retrouvez encore
plus ici parce que voyez vous avez un
lecteur de cartes sd et des lecteurs de
cartes sd aujourd'hui on ne retrouve pas
partout et souvent à 11 ans aia pas de
lecteur de carte sd pourtant c'est une
machine pour les créatifs
là vous en avez une beaucoup ne
comprends pas parce que vous êtes
vraiment dans l'adn du créatif vous êtes
dans vos studios vous pouvez prendre
l'enlever pour les griffonné vous pouvez
travailler un peu partout c'est vraiment
de la modularité
mais vous n'avez pas assez de puissance
vous n'avez pas de port thunderbolt roi
tout ça en 2020 avec ce qui existe
ailleurs sans marcher six ans le marché
avec microsoft avec ce produit là je
vous dirais banco en débat mais
aujourd'hui il ya du monde et c'est là
ça devient vraiment compliqué et voyez
ce que j'arrive pas à comprendre non
plus là dessus c'est qu'on est vraiment
sur une machine de 2020 avec un design
qui n'est pas un design de 2020 en 2020
on a des machines avec des bords qui
sont quand même beaucoup plus fin autant
je trouve que cette partie là et
toujours bien réussi mise à part le
trackpad
autant je trouve la charnière est
toujours canon et c'est vraiment le gros
point fort de ce produit là autant je
trouve que l'écran fait extrêmement
massif par rapport à ce que vos trois
notamment son dernier macbook pro c'est
ce pouce et là je ne parle pas encore de
l'xp est reste
dell de 2020 qui lui fait extrêmement
mal regardé les bords alors
effectivement ces modèles 13 pouces et
par modèle 15 pouces il existe un modèle
15 pouces mais ça c'est le 13 pouces
mais regardez la différence c'est
absolument incroyable alors on pourrait
se dire c'est justifié parce que vous
avez une webcam vous avez windows est
logé voulait d'ailleurs quelques
instants mais vous avez également une
webcam qui est planqué justice'' de la
miniaturisation donc même si l'ensemble
écoulée notamment grâce au niveau de la
charnière et de cette partie de clavy
qui est très sympa il ya quand même
vieilli en 2020 une fois de plus c'est
un peu moyen je vais pas lui adresser
que des critiques parce qu'une fois de
plus j'adore ce boîtier en magnésium et
j'adore l'idée de cette charnière c'est
vraiment le point le plus important et
je crois que c'est là où et toute la
valeur de microsoft c'est peut-être
l'erreur sur le produit de cette fête se
dire ok on a une charnière qui est nos
ventes ok on a un brevet ok on est les
seuls à faire ce qu'on fait donc on le
fait peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on aurait
pu utiliser cette charnière un peu
différemment est ce qu'il aurait pas
fallu revoir le prix de ce produit est
ce que c'était possible de revoir le
prix se produit je voulais taille c'est
quand même un peu cher est-ce que la
charnière est suffisante à elle même
pour justifier justement tournant il
trouvé ce produit moi je pense
honnêtement que si quelqu'un aujourd'hui
va acheter le sur facebook 3 c'est parce
qu'il est amoureux du système détachable
on puisse le mettre à l'envers mais
qu'ils s'en fichent derrière d'avoir de
la performance parce que si on veut
beaucoup de performances sont les
infographies sion des créateurs on a
besoin de performance a besoin tout le
temps de performance on peut pas être
handicapé et aujourd'hui c'est le cas
pourtant vous avez un écran pixelsense
de 15 pouces de qualité avec une
résolution de 3240 par 2160 pixels à 2
160 pixels par pouces un écran qui est
complètement tactile ce qui n'est pas le
cas de tous les ordinateurs du marché
donc ça aussi c'est très très bien vous
avez une expérience globale en termes de
visionnage qui est vraiment agréable si
vous voulez acheter du contenu
multimédia c'est là vous allez avoir le
plus de possibilités mais une fois de
plus est ce qu'on va mettre de telles
sommes dans un ordinateur comme ça juste
pour un côté multimédia vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo et d'olbia tu nous
sors ça c'est aussi un truc un peu
bizarre une fois de plus par rapport à
ce qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui à dire que
vos parleurs sont forcément ici et non
pas dans la partie de base pour vous
puissiez l'entendre vous avez beau
parleur qui sont situées des deux côtés
ici et ici et vous allez avoir un son
qui va être un peu imprécis qui va
manquer un peu d'attac qui va manquer
aussi de rondeurs qui va être un peu
dans le médium qui fera la faire mais
lorsque vous le comparez à ce que pour
trouver notamment chez apple avec le
macbook pro 16 pouces
eh bien il ya un écart qui est quand
même vraiment énorme maintenant ils font
ça extrêmement ingénieux d'avoir séparé
les bas
si vous avez une batterie de 67 cas chez
celui-ci 67 watts heure dans la base
dans la structure pourra dire comme vous
dans le clavier en tout cas et dans
l'écran vous avez une batterie de 23
watts heure plutôt malin répartition
aussi du poivre ou saas tiens pourquoi
pas par contre un truc qui va vachement
surpris c'est le bloc de charge
le bloc de charge quand je les prie en
main je les trouvais extrêmement lourd
il fait un peu plus de 450 grammes et si
on vient peser le bloc de charge du
macbook pro on est à un peu moins de 400
grammes on est à 375 380 grammes alors
tout ça c'est une question g et
probablement deux points de détails mais
je puis vous assurer que lorsque vous le
prenez on sent un peu plus lourd après
est ce que dans un sac vous allez sentir
réellement la différence est ce que
c'est d'être handicapant je ne suis pas
sûr non plus ici on tourne sur windows
dix familles
vous connaissez windows dix pensent que
je vais pas vous apprendre grand chose
là dessus ça marche très bien ces
pratiques pétards plein de choses avec
et si vous êtes en entreprise vous
pouvez même avoir windows dix
professionnels ont collectif déjà trouvé
deux prises usb à trois points de
deuxième génération un lecteur de carte
sd une prise usb ces trois points 20 ans
et si je voulais dit pas de symboles 3
c'est un peu incompréhensible 1%
passionnel pour venir le recharger et
ici la prise jack est la prise jack
comment dire qui a eu cette idée alors
effectivement c'est un héritage de
l'ancien modèle qui veut avoir une prise
jack qui est positionné juste ici et qui
pendouille avec le câble ça paraisse un
truc qui aurait dû être vu et qui pour
le coup ne l'est pas alors je comprend
une fête plus pour l'idée de la voir en
mode tablette
eh bien vous avez toujours avec vous
votre prise jack il ya un côté pratique
vous pouvez la mettre dans le sens que
vous voulez sur le bas sur le côté pour
le tourner ok ça c'est très bien mais
par contre lorsque vous allez l'utiliser
en mode pc est là c'est pas terrible
alors rassurez-vous vous toujours
brancher un casque sans fil parce que
oui vous avez du bluetooth 5.0
d'ailleurs là pour le coup microsoft
s'est mis à l'heure actuelle en tout cas
en mode 2020 avec du wifi cif donc ça
s'est vraiment bien
on a également la puce tpm 2.0 pour la
sécurité et vous avez une journée
également parlé vous avez de webcam
alors que les webcams pourquoi pas
notamment aujourd'hui pour la question
du télétravail vous avez à l'arrière
justice et une caméra de 8
higuain pixels avec la mise au point
automatique pouvait faire de la vidéo
jusqu'en 1080p très bien et vous avez à
la vente dans ce gros modules là et bien
vous avez une caméra de 5 mégapixels
avec un windows et l'eau pour venir
déverrouiller de façon sécurisée
extrêmement rapide votre ordinateur
et ça marche extrêmement bien et c'est
vraiment mais vraiment très appréciable
et je vous ai pas parlé des boutons
physiques puisque oui si vous avez un
bouton physique pour venir l'allumé pour
l'éteindre et ici un bouton pour venir
monter et baisser le volume en mode
tablette c'est extrêmement pratique les
balles à je suis un peu embêté et
microsoft vous savez que j'aime vos
produits j'aime les innovations j'aime
bien cette boîte qui vous savez il ya un
lien très affectif avec microsoft moi
quand j'étais gamin les premiers
ordinateurs que j'ai connus tour n'est
même pas sur windows 95 ensuite aux
windows 95 98 tu vises a enfin vous
connaissez l'histoire et au niveau
hardware ils font des choses que je
trouve bien qu'ils sont vraiment cool et
j'aime beaucoup ce que fait microsoft et
j'aime beaucoup et l'idée de cette
machine là et l'idée d'avoir un trois en
un pc tablette mode studio autant c'est
extrêmement pertinent en 2015 2017 2018
mais en 2020 on s'y perd un peu
et j'ai l'impression que microsoft n'a
pas su prendre la mesure aujourd'hui du
marché de la concurrence ça paraît
dingue je pense que oui quand même
ou alors c'est moi qui me trompe ou un
ordinateur va vraiment rencontré un
grand succès commercial et satisfaire
plein de clients plein de consommateurs
qui au final n'ont pas besoin de
beaucoup de performances je sais pas
pour moi il ya un truc qui colle plus il
ya un truc qui colle pas j'adore une
fois de plus l'idée de la charnière
l'idée l'écran qui détache c'est
vraiment génial
il lui manque un petit quelque chose qui
pourrait en élidé plus loin pour réussir
à redéfinir ce produit parce que oui en
2020 ce produit doit être redéfinie on
doit réussir à comprend ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire avec cette machine là
qu'on ne peut pas faire ailleurs avec
une tablette plus serré qu'à
l'ordinateur
parce que une fois de plus avec le
présentateur là vous pouvez facilement
vous achetez aujourd'hui un bon pc est
également une excellente tablette parce
que cette petite bête là coûte dans la
version 15 pouces toujours 16 giga de
ram 256 giga de stockage ont trop petit
en tout cas c'est parce que je vous
conseille mais le tarif c'est quand même
deux 1599 euros voyez tout de suite si
vous montez sur les versions 32 gigas de
ram ce qui est super pour pouvoir
travailler plus 512 ya de stockage c'est
à 3099 euros c'est quand même une
certaine somme skype un gros budget et
32 gel de stockage 1 tera vous passez à
3349 euros autant vous dire c'est quand
même relativement cher et si vous voulez
passer
la config en 13 pouces et demi 8 gigas
de ram 256 go de stockage vous êtes à
1779 euros ce qui est malgré tout une
somme donc la question se pose
aujourd'hui non pas par rapport à ce
produit est ce qu'il est cool
il est très cool d pour avoir son écran
détaché 2 mais dans l'autre sens la
charnière aimanté kivu le bloc c'est
génial l'innovation est encore là et il
n'a pas trop vieilli
mises à part quelques points de détails
du deal trackpad bon voilà c'est des
points dont on pourrait discuter mais
des de la charnière reste toujours très
modernes sont très actuelles
j'aime beaucoup mais son positionnement
par rapport à ce qui existe sur le
marché par rapport à une gamme qui s'est
complexifiée par rapport des tablettes
qui sont vraiment monter en gamme
vous pouvez avoir un pc et une tablette
au prix cette machine là et ça sera
beaucoup plus performant que ce que vous
avez ici c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup
de mal et j'aurais du mal à vous le
recommander sauf si vous tombez vraiment
amoureux ce système là que vous avez pas
besoin de beaucoup de performances et
que vous voulez mettre beaucoup d'argent
dans une machine funky c'est un peu
l'idée a vous de me dire vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire ça
vous intéresse bien évidemment josé mis
un lien pouvez cliquer dites moi
honnêtement vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu là sur
facebook 1 est ce que vous avez eu la
surface nous deux et est ce que vous
pourriez avoir c'est pas déjà fait et là
sur facebook trois marques moi tout ça
en bas pour commenter annonceurs ou
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler texte vous croyez moi là que tu
n'arrêtes pas ya plein de choses de tous
les côtés c'est vraiment des gars vous
aurez beaucoup d'amour ayant très vite
ciao ciao
[Musique]
service